All throughout scripture, God's people clunked
to his promises, promises
of a king who will come, a savior
who will reign, a redeemer,
who will bring light into the darkness.
True Jesus. God's plan unfolds
from promise to presents.
Isn't that beautiful? Uh,
our team did a great job on that.
We'll show that for the next few weeks.
If you are new, uh, my name is John. I'd love to meet you.
I'm one of the pastors here. I get to preach most
of the time, and so it's an honor to do that.
But it is an honor to meet you as well.
Uh, if you are ready at some time,
whenever that is, you can scan that QR code in front of you
or you can take that card out to the seat, out to the lobby
and would meet someone there.
We wanna help just connect you deeper in your faith, uh,
hopefully to our church as well,
but, uh, primarily to Jesus more
so help us help you with that.
Also, let me remind you that it is, uh, today,
actually maybe tomorrow, I got one email this morning.
The QR code that you'll see on the screen gets you the daily
advent email leading up to Christmas.
And so this is just a way for us to prepare together,
Aaron Ferguson, put it together for us.
Uh, make sure you're signed up for that.
It's a great opportunity to prepare your heart
rightly for Christmas.
If you miss it on the screen, it's on your notes
as well if you didn't get that QR code in time.
But it is officially Christmas season now
that we are past Thanksgiving.
I don't know if that's your philosophy or not,
but uh, here we are officially now.
And so we wanted to take these next few weeks just to walk
through the actual story of what happened 2000 years ago.
A lot of people are familiar with generalized ish kind
of ways that they feel like they know the Christmas story,
but this will actually, Luke one
and two will clarify it for us.
Not only that, it all beautifully relates back to
what we just finished walking
through in First and second Samuel.
It ties together that we were looking back then
for the promised King.
Well, here he actually shows up.
So from promise to presence,
his is the throne of his father David.
What that means for us today then is this,
if you remember nothing else, you can remember this today,
is that God keeps his promises even
through unexpected means and unworthy people.
God keeps his promises. That's what we're gonna learn today.
God keeps his promises even through unexpected means
and unworthy people.
We saw glimpses of that truth throughout one and two Samuel.
I mean, God used supernatural events
and sinful people
to accomplish his purposes in Israel back then.
So we've seen glimpses of it,
but now we will see it in living color right here
in Luke one and two.
And here's why this is so important for us today.
This is not just to help us have a little more
sweet Christmas season, like this is not
for cinnamon mentality.
What we're talking about here is the reality.
Knowing some of you may be in the fog of doubt right now
or, or you see events in your life
and you're thinking, man, there's no way
that God could be good.
I, I look at this situation
and I'm just thinking like, man,
does he really have a plan here?
It doesn't seem like it. It sure seems like all I'm getting
is just pounded left and right.
No, this, this can't be good.
And so with that as the background,
that's why we look at this a little more afresh today,
that God keeps his promises even
through unexpected means and unworthy people.
So let's pray towards that end together now, Lord,
we do ask you to use your word today to speak to
that person who's questioning
whether this stuff is really legit or not.
You would speak to that person who's looking at their
situation in life and just thinking, there's no way out.
There's hopeless situations all around me. Can God be good?
Does God have a plan? Lord, show us today.
Remind us as we walk into the storm later in life,
remind us of these truths today that you keep your promises.
Speak that to our tr, our minds, our hearts,
that we would not lose sight in this Christmas season.
We'd not lose sight of what it's really all about.
You keep your promises, Lord, teach us today in Jesus' name.
Amen. So if you're not already there, go ahead
and turn with me in your copy of God's word
to the gospel according to Luke chapter one.
If you're unfamiliar with the Bible, that's about three
fourths of the way through, uh,
you'll hit the New Testament, we call it.
That's Matthew begins it, then Mark, then Luke,
just chapter one, first words of it, we call it the gospel.
According to Luke, it means the good news of Jesus according
to meaning from his perspective.
But, but this is just the researched historical account
of the good news about Jesus, what he did, who he was,
what he said, all of that.
In fact, that's what he starts
with in the first four verses right here, verses one
through four of chapter one says, in as much
as many have undertaken to compile a narrative of the things
that have been accomplished among us, just as those
who were from the beginning were eyewitnesses
and ministers of the word have delivered them to us,
it seemed good to me also having followed all things closely
for some time past to write an orderly account
for you most excellent Theophilus,
that you may have certainty
concerning the things you have been taught.
So here's what we know about Luke from historical records.
What we see of Luke is that he was a physician,
which means he was a researcher.
He wasn't just gonna take it stock value,
he was going to study it.
He was somebody who was not originally part
of the 12 that followed Jesus.
He was coming to faith a little bit later
as they shared the gospel with him.
And here's what I love about Luke is he would not have been
one to just take it from face value and just believe it.
'cause you said it right? He's going, think about it.
He's going to look into it.
He's not gonna take this faith stuff lightly.
To him then belief was reasonable. He looked into it.
He was was
of course God opened his eyes and heart to see it.
But he looked at all the facts.
He looked at all the history. He asked a bunch of questions.
And even in that in many ways
because of that, he believed
that's what he was doing here for Theophilus, this recipient
of his writings, both Luke and Ax.
We don't know who Theophilus actually was.
It could have been a pseudonym for somebody else
to protect the guy he was writing to,
or most likely it was used as a catchall
name for a group of people that he's writing this
for a generalized audience.
People who imagine this,
who had received some instruction about Jesus.
They were probably believers in Jesus,
but for some reason they needed to be reassured
of the reliability of the information they'd been receiving.
Like, okay, is this I, I think I believe this,
but ah, I just need some confidence in it.
So that's what he's doing here.
He's giving Theophilus, you're giving this group
of people the truth of the history, the facts
of the history, which was important of course some,
some backing to the events that was important.
But he was not just giving them a factual
rundown of what happened.
He was also speaking of the belief that those facts
would lead to, right?
It wasn't just a set of history, right?
This is not just a history book. It does tell us history.
It is historical, but it's not just that.
It's also leading people to believe in the one it speaks of.
And so these people had believed
and now they're needing the foundation behind it
and the certainty of it.
And Luke's like, I got you. Here it is.
He provided a solid basis
for their faith in Jesus Christ.
And so for us then we're gonna see a lot of promises
that Luke shows were fulfilled.
What that means is
that when we look at the promises from our perspective,
looking back at all, God has said, all God has done
what we know first
and foremost here is that God's promises stand
as historically certain.
That's guarantee.
What we learn here first is that God's promises stand as
historically certain.
All God has said, all God has promised, all God has done.
It's historically certain the
gospel, we talk about the good news about Jesus.
It's not just a myth, it's not just a legend.
It's not just some story we came up with
to make ourselves feel better.
This is eye witness testimony that is carefully researched
and handed down, right?
You know how it works. You've seen those courtroom shows,
hopefully not been in court too often,
but you've seen the shows, right?
That you, you see the most credible thing
that is presented in a courtroom is eyewitness testimony.
Like, I saw it happen. That's the guy, right?
That's the one. They did it. They were not there.
All of that eyewitness testimony brings the most behind it.
This is eyewitness testimony.
What Luke was researching, recording,
writing down, investigating.
That's why we can stake our eternity on it.
This is not just somebody sitting in a room writing a story.
This is researched eyewitness accounts.
Notice Luke says, I followed all things closely.
He was involved, he was looking into it.
He was writing then an orderly account.
What that means is that God cares about facts.
God cares about and works in history.
This is not a parallel universe
where we're living a life here and there
and we're living out the facts of history
and God's paralleling it over here with some kind of myth.
That's a legend. That's a story.
No, he's working in real history, not just spiritual ideas.
Nebulous, nothingness out there.
This is real entered into our lives kind of history.
That's the story of Christmas.
That's why we can look at this
and say these are historically certain.
That's also why when we talk about Christian hope,
we're not just talking about like a wishful thinking, man,
I really hope my team wins this week.
I really hope this happens.
I really hope I get that for Christmas.
So not just wishful thinking,
this hope we are talking about Christian hope is anchored in
the bedrock of historical reality.
We have hope for the future because something happened,
because God exists.
We know we have hope for the future
because of that historical
Reality.
And that's the trend in our day.
So much of our world floats through life
with this vague sense of something spiritual happening.
Even Christians can trend towards that.
That it's all about this spirituality and spiritualism
and you're just kind of feelings based.
And everything's about this idea.
No dig into the certainty of what God has done.
The certainty of it.
It's good that in an age of relativism
and fake news, God says,
I have entered into history.
I have acted, tested, evaluated.
You can rest your soul on this.
It's Good news for us that something certain
Exists.
God keeps his promises
and those promises stand as historically certain.
And he does that even through
unexpected means and unworthy people.
So watch what Luke recorded first.
He's researched, he's writing this account.
Here's what he starts with.
Verse five, in the days of Herod king
of Judea, there was a priest named Zacharia
of the division of Ajam.
He had a wife from the daughters of Aaron
and her name was Elizabeth.
And they were both righteous
before God, walking blamelessly in all the commandments
and statutes of the Lord.
But they had no child because Elizabeth was barren
and both were advanced in years.
And so it's interesting that the first thing Luke chooses
to record has nothing to do with the person
that eventually we talk about all the time.
He starts with Zechariah and Elizabeth.
It doesn't start with Mary, it doesn't start with anybody.
Jesus. He starts with Zechariah, this godly man
who was a priest in Israel at the time,
and it tells us a little bit about his wife, Elizabeth.
Her situation, their situation
and the details are important.
I say this every time, we can't skip over the details
of the Bible
because verse six says, they were both righteous
before God walking blamelessly in all God's commandments.
But that did not mean their life was perfect as
A result.
Verse seven. But they had no child
because Elizabeth was barren
and both were advanced in years.
Here's what that means contextually back then.
That means probably for decades, Elizabeth walked around
considered less than some shame,
heaped on her as she watched sisters,
cousins, nieces get pregnant, have babies,
and she's decades after decades barren.
It was considered a curse in some ways.
And I'm sure if you try to put yourself in her shoes,
that would've tempted her to doubt God, wouldn't it?
God, does God really have a good plan in store for our life?
I mean, this is the thing we are praying for.
We want we long for. It's a good desire.
It's not sinful, it's not an idol.
We want a baby, but God, you're not answering that.
Why are you really good? Do you really have a good plan?
But I don't. I want you to feel that part of it,
but don't miss what it says here about them.
That was true. You can feel the weight of that.
But don't miss that. They both still remained faithful.
They walked righteously.
They were blameless, they were hurting,
they were feeling less than there was this sense of man,
where is God in this situation?
Yet they both still remained faithful the entire time
and watch what happened next.
Starting in verse eight. Now, while he was serving as priest
before God, when his division was on duty, according
to the custom the priesthood, he was chosen by lot
to enter the temple of the Lord and burn incense.
The whole multitude of the people were praying
outside at the hour of incense
and there appeared to him an angel
of the Lord standing on the right side
of the altar of incense.
And Zechariah was troubled when he saw him
and fear fell upon him.
But the angel said to him, do not be afraid.
Zechariah, for your prayer has been heard.
And your wife, Elizabeth will bear you a son.
You should call his name John.
You'll have joy and gladness
and many will rejoice at his birth for he will be great
before the Lord and he must not drink wine or strong drink
and he'll be filled with the Holy Spirit,
even from his mother's womb
and he will turn many of the children of Israel
to the Lord their God.
He will go before him in the spirit
and power of Elijah to turn the hearts of the fathers
to the children and the disobedient to the wisdom
of the just to make ready for the Lord a people prepared.
Now, you can't question the sovereignty
of God in this situation
because the way they would do it,
all these priests would stand out there
and it was by lot almost like dice.
They would throw these and say, all right,
you're up because of this.
And so as they did that, who happened to get the lot
that time Zechariah
because God wanted him in the temple at this moment
for this purpose.
And so God sovereignly puts Zechariah in the temple.
He's fulfilling his priestly duties.
God then sends this angel we discover later is Gabriel
who shows up a couple times in these two chapters.
He shows up. Gabriel says to Zechariah,
verse 13, what does he say?
Your prayer has been heard
the prayer that Zechariah
and Elizabeth had been praying potentially for decades.
Gabriel says, your prayer's been heard.
Just as a side note, it's not wrong to pray for something
that God places on your heart as a desire from him.
You wanna be married. It's not an
idol, but you want to be married.
You long for that. Pray for it.
You want a child, pray for it. You want a job, pray for it.
Like those things are not wrong to pray for as long
as they don't become an idol, they're not wrong to pray for.
This is a good desire.
Yet part of trusting God in that is submitting
to God's timing in
that 'cause.
They might have seemed like, man, this is too late.
It's been decades. We're advanced in years. Like what?
What do we do? It's too late, right?
But in God's perfect plan, now is the time.
Not five years ago, not 40 years ago. Now is the time.
This is the moment. This is when God had ordained
that this is going to be the specific child they get.
His name was gonna be John.
Don't don't doubt.
Even if it takes longer than you think it should.
Now Gabriel interestingly describes the child to Zacharia
And as he describes this baby what he's going to be,
it all points to John being a prophet about the strong drink
and what he's gonna be and what he's gonna do.
All that's pointing to John being a prophet, which is great,
but it's not just any prophet.
It's a prophet. He says that would be like Elijah,
widely considered the greatest prophet in Israel's history.
Like this baby, you're gonna get
zacharia, not just any old baby.
This is gonna be the one like the the greatest one,
the Elijah like figure coming to Israel.
And again, details matter 'cause look again verses 16
and 17, Gabriel says,
and he will turn many of the children
of Israel to the Lord their God.
He will go before him.
We don't know who him is yet in the spirit
and power of Elijah to turn the hearts of the fathers
to the children, the disobedient to the wisdom of the just
to make ready for the Lord a people prepared.
Now I want you to listen with that in mind
to the very last words of the Old Testament.
Malachi chapter four, the very last thing God said
before, 400 years of silence
until this moment when Gabriel shows up,
that's the the breaking of 400 years of silence.
The very last thing God said back in Malachi four,
behold I will send you Elijah, the prophet before the great
and awesome day of the Lord comes
and he will turn the hearts of fathers to their children
and the hearts of children to their fathers.
Lest I come and strike the land
with a decree of utter destruction.
See that right? This, this is who this baby's gonna be.
Zechariah hears from Gabriel that that his son John is going
to be that Elijah figure that Malachi four said
and then 400 years of silent.
This is the promise fulfilled from 400 years ago.
He's going to be the one to prepare the way for the Messiah.
That's where he said he will go before him. Who's him?
The Messiah Before God shows up,
this baby, John's gonna grow up
and prepare the way for that king to come.
Now, I dunno about you,
but if an angel showed up in my room, I would tend
to believe him, right?
I don't know, maybe I'm just, I'd be
so terrified I'd be on my face.
I couldn't, couldn't speak Richard.
By the way, every time an angel shows up
to anybody in the Bible, the first thing they have
to say is like, don't be afraid.
Like 'cause you're terrified.
This shining man just comes, shows up in your room like,
yeah, that'd be terrifying.
Don't be afraid. Well watch how Zechariah responded
to this verse 18.
And Zacharia said to the angel, how shall I know this
for I am an old man and my wife is advanced in years.
I'm glad he didn't call her old.
He just said advanced in years.
So you can use that one later if you want to.
But he just said she's advanced in years. I'm old.
My wife's advanced years. How is this going to be possible?
He looked at his situation.
He had heard all the angel what it said.
He looked at the the facts of the situation.
He's like, man, there's no way this,
this is biologically impossible.
Look, we've already tried for decades. This is not working.
This is not possible. I'm old, she's advanced in you.
This is not going to work.
But listen, let's give him a little bit of grace here.
'cause don't we all do that? To an extent, isn't
that the human condition that we sit here
and we look at an a seemingly impossible
situation and we think there's no way.
You look at a dead marriage, you look at a prodigal child,
you look at the debt that's looming over you
and you just think there's no way out.
This is an impossible situation.
So yeah, Zechariah was looking at his situation
thinking, this is impossible.
We do the same thing.
But aren't you thankful that we serve a God
who specializes in resurrection?
And we're gonna watch a little bit later in chapter one,
how God fulfills this promise to Zechariah.
Like it comes to pass, it happens.
But I want you to see like we kind of sat in the feeling
of Elizabeth, that she's doubting and questioning.
This is Zechariah's turn.
And he's doubting, he's questioning what is going on.
I don't understand how this could be possible. Watch how God
Responds To Zechariah here starting verse 19.
And the angel answered him, I am Gabriel.
I stand in the presence of God
and I was sent to speak to you
and to bring you this good news.
Meaning like, Hey, don't take it up with me.
Take it up with the Father. Like he's the one who sent me.
He's got this under control.
And behold, you'll be silent
and unable to speak until the day
that these things take place because you did not believe
My words, Which will be fulfilled in their time.
And the people were waiting for zacharia.
And they were wondering at his delay in the temple.
And when he came out, he was unable to speak to them.
And they realized he'd seen a vision in the temple
and he kept making signs to them and remained mute.
And when his time of service ended, he went to his home.
Verse 24, after these days, his wife Elizabeth conceived.
And for five months she kept herself hidden, saying,
thus the Lord has done for me in the days when he looked on
me to take away my reproach, that shame among people.
Here's what I want you to see with this
zechariah's unbelief could not stop God's plan.
God did it. He,
he saw this happen in his wife.
He saw this happen in their lives. Zechariah's.
Unbelief could not stop God's plan,
but hear me, it can silence our praise.
'cause you were designed, created by God to worship,
to praise him that your life would reflect the glory
and goodness of God.
That's what you are created and designed to do.
That's what you're supposed to do.
But if we doubt that God can truly bring light out of dark
life, out of death hope, out of uncertainty, if we doubt
that, then the praise we were designed to give
will be quenched.
He was made mute because he didn't believe.
So here's what I want us to learn from this.
Here's, I believe God gave this to us
To today.
'cause I know a lot of situations.
I know people are going through a lot as we deal
with God's promises and think about who God is.
Here's here's the point.
God's promises overcome human impossibility
Every time.
God's promises will always overcome
human impossibility.
We look at our situation, we look at our lives,
we look at this whole thing around us
and we think this thing is impossible.
There's no way out. We see an insurmountable hurdle.
But we forget God can do whatever he wants.
And what God promises he accomplishes.
If he's promised it, he performs it.
Even when biology or age
or barrenness, it all screams impossible to zacharia.
But the Lord can create something out of nothing.
Don't you remember Genesis one,
the very first page in the beginning there was nothing
and God spoke and there was something.
That's what God does.
He by definition can bring something out of nothing.
He can do that in Zacharia and Elizabeth
and he can do that in your life
Too.
And he doesn't need your Strength.
Again, spoke and something out of nothing.
He doesn't need your tools. He doesn't need your strength.
Like, man, I can't work through them. They're too weak.
No, he doesn't need your strength.
What he needs is your faith.
He needs zacharia to look at him
and say, okay, God, you got this.
I'm in. He needs you to say, I don't understand this.
It doesn't look like anything. He's gonna come
of this, but God, I believe you.
This is your promise. I'm standing on it.
That's what he needs. He needs your faith.
He brought about the Savior,
the world in unexpected ways here in Luke one and two.
He can do whatever he wants in your life too. Trust him.
Just trust him. It may not turn out
like you thought it would.
It may be decades
later than you thought it was gonna happen.
But he will accomplish what he
Promised.
Trust him.
Well, here's what I love about how Luke
Set this up.
'cause that was hard. I mean, Zacharia question,
he's going with mute for a while like that.
Okay? As that was going on with Zacharia and Elizabeth
and their life and the promise
and all that stuff happening happening,
Gabriel wasn't done working yet.
He continued his assignment. Next, look at verse 26 to 33.
In the sixth month, the angel Gabriel was sent from God
to a city of Galilee named Nazareth to a virgin Betroth,
to a man whose name was Joseph of the house of David.
The Virgin's name was Mary.
And he came to her and said, greetings, oh favored one.
The Lord is with you. But she was greatly troubled at the
saying, trying to discern
what sort of greeting this might be.
And the angel said to her, do not be afraid, Mary,
for you have found favor with God.
Behold, you will conceive in your womb and bear a son
and you shall call his name Jesus.
He'll be great and he'll be called the son of the most high.
And the Lord God will give
to him the throne of his father David.
And he will reign over the house
of Jacob forever and of his kingdom.
There will be no end.
And so here's the difference.
That promise to Zachary
and Elizabeth was an awesome promise.
I mean barren for decades. Finally, get a baby.
He's gonna be a cool dude. Like this is gonna be awesome.
It's great. But that pales in comparison to the promise
that is even greater right here.
The incarnation of the son of the most high, the son of God,
the second person of the Trinity taking on flesh
and dwelling among us.
That is overwhelmingly stunning.
And here's the cool part. If you've been with us
for the last few months, those last two verses I read
should sound familiar
because this is exactly the covenant that God made
with David all the way back in two Samuel seven.
I wanna read it to you. Listen to this.
This is what God said to David, said, David,
here's my covenant with you.
This is what I promise to you, David.
When your days are fulfilled
and you lie down with your fathers,
I will raise up your offspring
after you who shall come from your body.
And I will establish his kingdom.
He shall build a house for my name.
I will establish the throne of his kingdom forever.
I will be to him a father,
and he shall be to me a son, the son of the most high.
See what's happening here,
this is a thousand years later when God said that to David,
he said, you're gonna have his son on the throne
who will be my son forever.
And you're gonna have this house
and you're gonna have this child on the
kingdom throne forever.
A thousand years later, we see
to marry this is who your son's gonna be.
The promise became presence.
And again, that promise to secondmental Elizabeth was great.
It was awesome. But this promise right here is
what it's all really about.
All those promises, even the promise about John,
even the promises from Genesis three through Malachi four,
they all center on this miraculous Messiah.
Everything, all the promises of God,
everything in the Old Testament,
everything in the New Testament, it all centers on this one,
this promise of the miraculous Messiah to come, the son
of the most high becoming like you and me to save us.
That's what it all revolves around
everything in the Old Testament.
Genesis three, Malachi four, the promise
of redemption was centered on a savior, this messiah
to come, a kinsman redeemer.
One who would come from the family in order
to redeem the family.
That's why this next piece of the puzzle is so important.
Again, this is not just sentimentality.
This is really critical.
Look at verses 34 through 38 of Luke one.
And Mary said to the angel,
how will this be since I'm a virgin?
And the angel answered her,
the Holy Spirit will come upon you
and the power of the most high will overshadow you.
Therefore, the child to be born will be called holy.
Set apart the Son of God.
Behold, your relative, Elizabeth,
in her old age has also conceived a son.
This is the sixth month with her who was called barren
because nothing will be impossible with God.
And Mary said, behold, I'm the servant of the Lord.
Let it be to me according to your word.
And the angel departed from her.
See, here's the reality, the fact
that Jesus was born of a virgin.
It's not just some party trick.
It's not just a cool miracle.
It actually has to do with why and how we are saved.
This is a big deal
because if the Son of God came only as God,
then he wouldn't be able to relate to us
and then wouldn't be able to redeem our bodies and creation.
He'd just be God and we'd be humans.
But the flip side, if he only has a sinful father
and a sinful mother, then he's not able
to be the sufficient sacrifice
to cover the penalty for our sins.
He's just another guy. That's why this is so important.
It has to be both God
and man, which is why he was born of a virgin.
He didn't have the seed of Adam, yours
and mine, that we of the sinful seed flowing through us.
And he also did have the flesh of humanity.
He's both God and man in one.
That's the mind blowing reality of Christmas.
That's why this was such a big deal.
It's not just an old couple conceiving, which is great,
but this was new creation beginning in a
teenage girl's womb.
This is the mixture of God
and man together as one fully God, fully man becoming flesh.
And that is the preview, the preview
of what is to come in the new creation someday God
and man together again, beginning
in a teenage girl's womb 2000 years ago,
it's the fulfillment of another promise.
This one, 700 years earlier,
Isaiah seven 14, read it earlier.
Therefore, the Lord himself will give you a sign.
Behold, the virgin shall conceive and bear a son
and shall call his name Emmanuel, which means God
with us 700 years.
Promise given. Promise fulfilled.
That's what Luke 1 37 said, nothing,
nothing will be impossible with God.
This barren couple conceives.
It's not impossible, this virgin getting pregnant.
It's not impossible, God taking on flesh.
It's not impossible. Nothing will be impossible with God.
That's why I love Mary's response.
Zacharias was a little questioning,
but Mary's response to Gabriel is faith.
Look at verse 38 again.
She said, behold, I am the servant of the Lord.
Let it be to me according to your word.
I'm in. I'm I'm your servant. I'm yours.
I am all in you. Do what you need to do. God.
See, none of these people deserved to be used by God.
Whether they were old and barren
or whether they were living in this backwoods cast off
town like Nazareth.
They did not deserve to be used by God.
Yet God used their very weakness
to glorify his name.
'cause here's what God was shouting to us through this.
Using this teenage girl, using this barren couple,
using all the different environments
that we'll see over the next couple chapters.
What God was shouting to us is
that salvation is his work, not ours.
They couldn't manufacture the Messiah.
Plenty of people tried along the way.
We're gonna rebel against Rome.
And they ended up getting squashed, right?
They, they couldn't manufacture the Messiah,
nor could they earn the Messiah.
They couldn't deserve him. They couldn't be good enough.
You can only receive the Messiah by faith
and say with Mary, behold, I am your servant.
Let it be to me, according to your word.
This is the point of Christmas
Church, This, that God has come.
None of us deserved it, but
because he's faithful to his promises, he
Came Thousands of years of promises.
He says, I'm gonna do, gonna do it. I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it. It's clear already in Luke one,
God was weaving together this beautiful tapestry
of all the promises showing up finally fully in Jesus
Christ, the long awaited Messiah.
It all culminates in this one.
That's why you and I should never allow Christmas
to become just sentimental.
It should be about certainty
that the promises find their yes
and amen in Jesus Christ alone.
And what that should do is should breed un expectant faith
that if God could do all that,
if God could keep his promises
and show up like that,
then expectant faith means when things look impossible.
I don't have to be cynical
because I serve a God of resurrection
and I serve a God who's kept his promises
for thousands upon thousands of years.
Why would he stop now?
And you might sit there and think, I'm unworthy.
I don't deserve that kind of love.
Don't let your unworthiness keep you from
Christ this Christmas.
In fact, your unworthiness is the only qualification you
need to come to Christ.
You realize you don't bring anything to the table,
you don't have anything to offer.
You are far from God. You are an enemy of God.
That is the very thing that says, okay, you're in
Because you see Jesus as the only hope, the only savior,
because it's from promise to presence.
The king has come.
I wanna invite our worship leaders to come out.
Now, I also wanna invite our prayer partners to go ahead
and go to the sidewalls here
because I wanna just explain for a second
what those opportunities are for you.
When we say prayer partners
nearly every week, we talk about that.
And, and what that means is that's an opportunity for you
to go talk to someone, ask for prayer
whenever you might need somebody else to, to have faith
for you right now.
And so here's a couple encouragement.
I would just say if, if maybe you have felt
Christmas become more sentimental, then certain,
and you've maybe doubted that this thing is really real
and it's just more about the lights and presents and,
and cookies and things and you're, you're needing
to just say, Hey, can you, can you pray
that God would light afresh that fire in my heart of
what Christmas is really about, of
what Jesus is really about?
And you ask for somebody to pray for you for that.
That's one way to do that. Or maybe,
maybe things do look impossible in your life right now.
You got something going on, some situation
that you feel like there's no way, no way out.
This is hopeless. And you need somebody to just kind
of believe for you for a second
and pray for you that you can take a baby step
into that kind of faith too.
Go ask for prayer from them as well.
Or maybe it's just, yeah, you feel unworthy.
You've never seen this kind of love before.
You've never seen this kind of Jesus,
this kind of God before.
And you just say, man, I,
I don't, I don't know what that's like.
Can you tell me what it means to really believe
and have a relationship with that God, they would love
to talk with you about that.
From promise to presence. He has come.
So at any point during the next few
minutes, go talk to one of them.
Go pray with them. Lord, we do pray in light
of your word today that you would lead us
to see you rightly, to see you as the God
that you are the promise keeper.
That not only do you make promises
and you can't back it up, you've made the promises.
You've proven that you have backed it up.
We have no doubt, no question that you can do it again.
And Lord, I know some of the stories in this room
that are heavy feel impossible.
But God, you are, you are not hindered.
You are not worried. You are not concerned about what
to us may seem impossible.
I thank you for that foretaste of glory, divine
of, of what is coming.
Lord, we, we talk about how you,
the Old Testament saints would've longed for you to come
for the Messiah to show up.
They were looking ahead to that.
We know that you have come, but we also long for the day.
You return Jesus and redeem it all and save us forever.
And so when we sing this come thou long expected Jesus.
We know they were praying that for you to come, Jesus,
we're praying that for you to come again Jesus
and to come reign in our hearts right now, help us trust you
even today as we long for the day, you come back.
Thank you God in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Let's stand together for you're able and worship.